[Music]
foreign
there are creatures and monsters from
the Dune Universe other than a massive
sand worm and here in this video we are
going to Showcase 13 of them The Deadly
Ones and the scary ones including the
mass of worm so let's get to it
the first one of course the sand worm
also known as the shy halad this
creature is a massive monster that is
found in the deserts of the planet
called arakis These are highly
territorial creatures that can grow up
to 450 meters or almost 1500 feet long
they are the ones that create the spice
melange a substance used by the people
in that Universe to be able to Traverse
through Subspace and also acts as a
mutagenic substance so the sand worm
basically resembles worms with a huge
mall that has rows of teeth or Frills
their body is cylindrical and are
worshiped by the desert people called
the Freeman on that planet
number two the hybrid spider this was
Baron hawkinen's pet it was a grotesque
black spider human hybrid which was
mutated and also to become this
monstrous creature it has eight limbs
that spread out from the enlarged
abdomen but the extremities of the limbs
produce hands with five fingers each it
has a human-like head which is black
like the rest of its body and two arms
are Sprout out from near its neck the
creature's abnormal motions were
designed to mimic the agony that a
former human being might experience
after being Twisted into the shape of a
spider
number three the sea worms if you think
sand worms were strange then its
subspecies will even be more weirder the
sea worms were sand worms at one point
of time and have been genetically
engineered produced and released into
the oceanic world of bazel when grown
into worm form the sand trouts the
juvenile ones they develop the ability
to live in a wet environment the
experiment was a huge success and the
sea worms began to overtake the water
ecosystem from the indigenous life forms
found there it was also discovered that
one of its internal organs contain a
highly strong kind of spice also called
the ultra spice
Number Four The Guild Navigators in
order to travel through Subspace
properly humans had to consume the spice
melange which was also a mutagenic
substance and so the guild Navigators
who after a long period of time of
constantly partaking in it become
evolved humans that appear monstrous and
hideous their bodies atrophy and mutate
over time with their heads and
extremities elongating and a skin
becoming a strange tone and texture and
the earliest outward symptoms of this
melange-induced metabolic alteration is
seen in its eyes where the medication
darkens the sclera and the iris appear
to be a very dark tone of blue which is
often mistaken to be black
number five the Axolotl tanks if you
think that the Star Wars Empire
experiments were inhumane then check out
Dunes these Axolotl tanks were living in
cubatas that produced living humans from
cells of dead bodies an advanced form of
clothing and incubating at the same time
but these Axolotl tanks were in fact
women who had been augmented and
drastically changed like mechanized
their wombs were utilized as incubators
the Tang according to Duncan Idaho is a
big frame with brilliant lights and
cushion mechanical hands as well as a
lady encircled by many black tubes
connecting her body to the steel
container they were capable of genetic
modifications and augmentations on
unborn individuals
number six the cymax here's the thing
about the Dune Universe it's a very
human-centric Galaxy and many of the
monsters and Boron creatures found in it
were once humans or rather mutated forms
of a person there were barely alien life
forms in that Universe assignment was a
sort of thinking machine that used to be
human but had been transformed into a
cyborg control by a human brain they
have existed for tens of Millennia
preceding the current timeline the cymax
human brain were preserved in an
electrofluid filled cylinder which
allowed it to live for tens of thousands
of years in this form
number 7 the god Emperor okay also known
as little at tradies II he was the son
of Border trades the one who was now
active in the recent Dune movies little
had powers strange powers that could
change the galactic order of things at
one point of time in order to follow on
through with his visions of the golden
path he allowed the sand worm to enter
him and was converted into a monstrous
sand worm human hybrid this
transformation was in the beginning just
an exoskeleton that gave him a boost in
physical abilities making him run faster
jump longer distances and all that jazz
but eventually he developed a body that
was mostly sand worm with the exception
of his upper torso that emerged out of
the gaping mouth intact with head chest
neck shoulders and arms
number eight omnius this is a robotic
and cybernetic form that is a collection
of powerful artificially intelligent
entities which theoretically rule a
section of space called the synchronized
Empire even though these AIS would be
created independently in different star
systems they would eventually link up
with one another and be considered a
single Unity or an entity sharing a
collective experience of their
counterparts though omnius theoretically
possessed no feelings and thus no
tangible personality it did appear to be
paranoid and genocidal against humans
later on in the timeline
number nine the D wolves these space
worlds were genetically engineered
hunters and guardians of little 2's
planet called sarir the gray bodies of
the D wolves were almost man height at
the shoulders around five to six feet
tall they are great hunters but have
been trained to see his following
Intruders at a location called the Idaho
rivers Water's Edge one of the
characters called siona mentions that
the wolf's eyesight was so sharp that
they could not miss anything even in the
Forbidden Forest a thick Everglades kind
of forest calling them gays hounds they
can eat whatever they catch in the
planet and hence are the Apex carnivores
number 10 the laser tiger the larger
tiger was a genetically modified
descendant of the old Earth's tiger that
was used to train soldiers in a planet
called seleusa secundus at Birth all
lots of tigers were implanted with a
control device that allowed them to be
controlled remotely they could thrive on
arrakis because they were
extraordinarily adaptive to severe
surroundings these Tigers were larger
faster and more aggressive than normal
ones
number 11 the electron electrons are
gigantic tentacle electrically charged
monsters that inhabit caledon's Waters
another planet in the Dune Universe few
are reported to exist at all and they
are only cited on rare occasions by Deep
Water fishermen most people on that
planet believe they are just myths and
legends electrons appear to be only
partially corporeal capable of retaining
any form when it touched with water
however they tend to lose stability and
form when less contact with water while
they are complex animals that are alive
in the most basic sense they still lack
cells and appear to exist only as
electrical energy
number 12 the face dancers these are
arrays of humans bred to become the
ultimate assassins infiltrators and
spies face dancers were able to take on
the physical appearance of any other
person their name was derived from the
fact that when they changed shape their
faces controlled and appear to dance as
the flesh moves face dances despite
being neither male or female had the
capacity to assume physical sex of the
person they were impersonating they
could not however reproduce as they were
made sterile from the start for fear of
propagation and growing out of control
13 the phibians amphibians are a
genetically modified humanoid sub rays
that first appeared and was first
referenced in Chapter House Dune they
are primitive humanoid fish creatures
taken to the million planets as
prisoners by the honored mattress a
strong all-female Society fibians are a
cross between humans and fish with low
intelligence and vocabulary they had
bullet shaped heads slick and
streamlined bodies and were taller than
humans they also had slick green skins
that shines out with an oily iridescence
as shown in the scattering which was a
historical event during the chaotic time
of the god emperor
so those are the 13 deadly monsters and
creatures from the Dune Universe I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit that like button for support and
subscribe and most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam